dieser mann hat zwei seiten
am tag ist michael schott winzer und
pflegt eine alte tradition
nachts wird er zum heavy metal sänger
zum rebell mit weiten der hand
uns inspiriert der wein und bei uns
gehört einfach dazu wie die verstärker
und schlagzeug vor einem jahr kam
michael schott mit seinem freund tobias
schäfer die idee aus beiden
leidenschaften ein geschäft zu machen
jetzt sind ihre schwarzen und extra
schweren flaschen auf dem markt wein für
heavy-metal-fans der name
michael schott spencer markt den wein
auch mit einem video mehr als zehn euro
kostet eine flasche heavy metal und
guter wein
das passt eigentlich eher nicht oder
produkt das aus wasser und erde wächst
und ausbrannte wenn wir das so nennen
kann und metal ist auch eine wahre musik
die vom einfach erfolg kommt für die
mettler gibt es ja den begriff das ist
das metal cruz sein muss also was gesagt
was ehrliches was was wahres nichts
gestelltes mehr unterhalten mal getraut
was neues zu machen
die einzigen die versuchen wein an harte
jungs zu bringen sind sie allerdings
nicht die deutsche rockband die toten
hosen vertreiben wein unter ihrem namen
the police
ac dc und die rolling stones sind auch
schon im weingeschäft am anfang war die
musik dann kam der wein als werbegag bei
michael schott war es umgekehrt
er stammt aus einer winzerfamilie steht
schon seit seiner kindheit an den
rebstöcken 17 hektar weinberge gehören
der familie hat in der beiden regionen
nahe im westen deutschlands
80.000 reden nur ein kleiner teil davon
geht in die matte war in produktion
wir haben hier von johannes beck auch
unser unserem riesling unserer
flaggschiffe unser familienweingut fj
das heißt also der ganze berg wird
sicherlich nie für den mittelrhein zu
haben sein
das war ein gut bewirtschaftet die ganze
familie gemeinsam
in der hauseigenen schnapsbrennerei
schuftet bruder benjamin
mutter ingrid und ehefrau claudia
organisieren den verkauf
vater ist der kopf des gesamten betriebs
er hat das weingut wiederum von seinem
vater übernommen
jeden mittag sitzen vier generationen
gemeinsam am tisch
auch die großmutter die einst das
weingut mit ihrem mann aufgebaut hat
neben den traditionsvereinen steht heute
auch der heavy metal wein auf dem tisch
ein bisschen fremd für mich aber lasst
die ohren doch machen was man machen
muss immer weiter gehen
genau dafür will der enkel sorgen dass
es mit dem weingut weitergeht
er will eine neue zielgruppe erreichen
sein rotwein heißt deswegen englisch
black hills tone loc der weiße
hergestellt hauptsächlich aus riesling
trauben eigentlich ganz traditionell sei
der wein trocken sein soll üblich seien
und wir haben uns so auf dem schon in
die trockene richtungen überlegt aber
halt eben nicht ganz trocken also so
dass wir auch dann praktisch nach zwei
drei gläsern einfach spaß hat weiter zu
feiern
einmal pro woche probt die band im
weinkeller eigentlich sind also alle
weile der familie schaut heavy metal
weine nicht nur die neue marke
der traum mehr wir spielen aufwarten und
du machst das catering das ist jetzt
eine metal wein ist das jetzt der neue
zielsetzung vorher waren also bei der
dorfkirmes jetzt also wacken das größte
metal festival der welt
dort soll die menge bald mit wein statt
mit bier in der hand feiern eigentlich
passend zum heavy metal immer gegen die
konvention